do you know why I'm excited to watch
this next how it should have ended video
because I'm Batman
hell man I wanted to you just come in
and steal my lawn you know what super
cafe the next night arises from his II
one of the greatest YouTube channels a
gift for all of YouTube let's watch have
they changed them I was afraid to show
them at this point people are gonna
judge you understand that why would you
just assume something how would I even
retrieve that with me much let's do with
the actual one I genuinely think turning
the gun to kill my parents into a
vegetable it's weird
so I want to know why you're asking me
what it is just let me have this
hey short sweet simple and funny I
appreciated that yeah love the setup of
this whole sketch I also really liked
how they get that feeling like it was
one shot of course it's only cut to get
it Andy Serkis
he's Gollum he's playing now for it in
this movie on the motorcycle I thought
was really funny but I loved how they
kept this in one shot the whole time I'm
marrying the test footage because they
could have easily done cuts it does feel
like a better riff on that test footage
that they did I love the commentary
they're making the jokes about how
people will judge you and I love that
crack why are you reading it is
something so specific that's something
that I'd comment on almost every time
we've talked about this Batman suit some
people have immediately sold themselves
on that that is the gun from the person
who killed his parents
we don't know guys we don't move might
not even bring it up at all if you could
just get aesthetic design so I love
other poking fun at that well it's a
good point of like how would he have
even found Joe chills gun to begin with
and also making fun of like the red
lighting because we've seen like the
test footage of things but it is such a
specific look the red mood that they
have provided this neo new or glanced
into it it does kind of make you
question why is it all read exactly yeah
let's his darkroom you know he's
developing photos in that scene is from
an actual moment in the movie because
Batman's a detective he takes his camera
around town and surveillance yeah I
really like together they like being
that this is a his evideo it doesn't
take on their normal structure and I
like that they just went with what were
the actual circumstances under which
this little tease might have been filmed
I hope that it seems like DC and Warner
Brothers are using this as part of their
ad campaigns now because I've seen them
for joke
we've seen them for birds of prey and
other things I think this could be a
really cool series for his e to keep
doing if these types of teases keep
dropping oh yeah just to add their
personalities to a Batman and Superman
oh yeah having a sexy world to come in
it's just a really funny bit there was a
time where was like hard to get
behind-the-scenes footage of things or
to get little snippets like Bleek's
quote-unquote and now they're just
publicly releasing them oh yeah even
like the bat-cycle thing that they poke
fun at how it's so great to make fun of
because looking at the bat-cycle footage
with a bad bike foot it just makes this
sue have a completely different feel to
it yeah and I mean this weirdly maybe
even though it's just as used for joking
purposes it did make me wonder did they
do that intentionally because of some
minor backlash that might have occurred
from the suit maybe one and I love that
they pointed out because one thing I
remembered thinking during that actual
test footage was I know they're not
showing they're making a point not to
show the ears yeah and and yeah and you
know they're in those leaked you know
stunt photos on the bike or whatever at
least a version of them are that's
obviously something people were going to
argue about I love that they went that
much further gave him legitimate bat
ears which I just I wasn't expecting
even though I was expecting a gag of
some kind this is really friggin funny
Thank You hissy for putting this short
and sweet simple sketch together so
there's a lot of work with all the
animation and I'm excited for more
Batman bits to come from you guys make
sure to subscribe to how it should have
ended if you haven't done so already you
can subscribe click our notification
bell as well thanks for telling us this
was out much love to everyone
you